.
♪ ♪
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
EVERYONE.
THERE'S ALWA  POINT WHERE YOU
KNOW THAT THERE IS A PIVOT POINT
AND A REVOLUTION.
>> THAT IS THE CASE WHEN BARACK
OBAMA WALKED INTO THE ROSE
GARDEN AND ANNOUNCED FORWARD
SELF-CONFIDENCE AND COOLNESS,
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATI
DECIDED NOT TO DEPORT MILLIONS
OF IMMIGRANTS.
IN FACT, THEY WOULD NO LONGER BE
CALLED ANYTHING BUT DREAMERS.
AND NO ONE STOPPED BARACK OBAMA
FROM DOING THIS AND SO HE DID IT
ANYWAY.
AND THE INTENDED EFFECT WAS
IMMEDIATE.
AND ABOUT 8000 UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS SHOWED UP TO THE U.S.
BORDER, AFTER THEY DEFINED THEM
AS DREAMERS, THE NUMBER HAS NOW
GROWN UNDER JOE BIDEN TO 100
30,000 PER YEAR AND INCREASE.
IT'S INTERESTING ON WHERE THEY
ARE COMING FROM.
NOT FROM A CONTINUOUS NATION.
MEXICO.
THEY ARE COMING FROM MUCH
FURTHER AWAY AS WELL.
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBERS FROM
THE HHS, 32% OF UNACCOMPANIED
MIGRANTS ARE FROM FROM HONDURAS,
THEN EL SALVADOR, THOSE ARE IN
CENTRAL AMERICA AS A COUPLE OF
COUNTRIES.
JUST 1% ARE COMING FROM MEXICO.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
WELL, MOSTLY THEY ARE TEENAGERS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY ARE
NOT JUST LITTLE KIDS, THEY ARE
ACCELERATED AND IT DID NOT STOP
DURING THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
AND UNDER THAT ADMINISTRATION
AGREED TO END FAMILY SEPARATIONS
AT THE BORDER AND ILLEGAL
ALIENS, DREAMERS, SHOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO FACE THESE
CONSEQUENCES, EXPLAINED "THE NEW
YORK TIMES."
BECAUSE THEY ARE DREAMERS.
SO NATURALLY, THE SEARCH
CONTINUES.
WELL, WHY?
BUT WHY?
WELL, TYPICALLY A COUNTRY
CALCULATES THE IMMIGRATION
LEVELS BASED UPON INTERNAL NEEDS
AND BASED ON THE STATE OF THE
UNITED STATES ECONOMY IN 2022,
THESE ARE NOT THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU WOULD IMPORT IF YOU CARE
ABOUT YOUR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT TRAINED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE EMERGING
ECONOMY THAT YOU CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT.
AND THERE'S NO ECONOMIC
JUSTIFICATION WHATSOEVER AND
S.T.E.M. DOES NOT PLAY A PART OF
IT, AND IMMIGRATION DESTABILIZES
A SOCIETY, IT MAKES IT FAR LESS
COHESIVE WHICH IS ALWAYS TRUE,
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE IT IS
COMING FROM AND ALSO BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID SO
REPEATEDLY IN PUBLIC FOR YEARS,
THIS IS A WAY THAT THEY EXPLAIN
IT.
THE HEAD DEMOCRAT, CHUCK
SCHUMER, SAID LAST MONTH, NOW
MORE THAN EVER WAS SHORT OF
WORKERS IN THE WORKFORCE, WE
HAVE A POPULATION THAT IS NOT
REPRODUCING ON ITS OWN WITH THE
SAME LEVEL THAT IT USE TO.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A GREAT FUTURE IN
AMERICA IS IF WE WELCOME AND
EMBRACE IMMIGRANTS.
DREAMERS AND ALL OF THEM BECAUSE
THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO HELP THE
DREAMERS TO GET A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL 11 MILLION
OR HOWEVER MANY UNDOCUMENTED
THAT THERE ARE HERE.
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT THAT WAS A
LOT ABOUT WE NEED WORKERS HERE.
7 MILLION AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN
WERE DROPPED OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE, THOSE THAT JUST
AREN'T WORKING ON THE INTERNET
EVERY DAY.
DOES ANYONE CARE?
JUST REPLACE THEM.
AND THE FOOD SUPPLY AND AIR HAVE
BEEN POISONED AND COUNTS ARE
HALF OF WHAT THEY WERE A FEW
DECADES AGO.
THESE ARE SPECIFIC PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE PREVENTED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND INSTEAD, THE
SOLUTION IS TO REPLACE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT REPRODUCING
WITH MILLIONS OF NEW PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THAT'S NOT A
RACIST CONSPIRACY THEORY, CHUCK
SCHUMER JUST SET IT.
HOWEVER MANY UNDOCUMENTED THERE
ARE HERE, HE ADDED.
THIS WAS A POLITICAL MATTER WE
ARE HEARING A LOT ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL EFFORT TO
DISENFRANCHISE AMERICAN VOTERS
IN AN ATTEMPT TO REPLACE THEIR
VOTE WITH THE NEW ELECTORATE AND
SO THIS IS INCREDIBLY.
>> THIS IS A MEASURE OF THE
PEOPLE BEHIND.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
CAN BECOME CODIFIED SINCE
REPUBLICANS TOOK OVER THE HOUSE.
BUT IT COULD BE.
IN THE LAME-DUCK SESSION WHICH
DOES NOT REPRESENT THE RECENTLY
EXPRESSED WILL OF VOTERS, LAST
MONTH, A MONTH AGO, VOTERS CAST
BALLOTS AND THEY SAID THAT WE
GOT ONE.
BUT THAT IS ALL ABOUT TO BE
SHORT-CIRCUITED.
REPORTING SUGGESTED THAT
DEMOCRATS AND SEVERAL
REPUBLICANS ARE WORKING ON A
DEAL TO PASS MASS AMNESTY FOR
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
BEFORE THE NEW CONGRESS CAN BE
SEATED AND THAT INCLUDES NOT
HOLDING AN IMMIGRATION BILL AND
YET SEVERAL REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE ARE TRYING TO PASS
A MASS AMNESTY BEFORE THE NEW
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS NEXT MONTH
AND WE SHOULD BECOME EFFORT FOR
THAT, TOM TILLIS OF NORTH
CAROLINA JOINED BY DEMOCRATS OF
ARIZONA THEY COULD INCLUDE THIS
PLAN INCLUDING STEPHEN COLLINS
OF MAINE AND MITT ROMNEY
INCLUDING ROB PORTMAN AND
OTHERS.
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE SOMEONE WHO
IS ON HIS WAY OUT AND IN DAYS
WILL BE CODIFYING A LAW THAT
WILL CHANGE THE COUNTRY FOREVER.
AND CLEARLY DONORS, IT'S A
SHORTSIGHTED VIEW AND THIS IS
OKAY BECAUSE IT WILL ONLY OFFER
THIS TO THE DREAMERS.
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS CAME TO THIS,
WHAT WILL HAPPEN NEXT AND WHAT
WILL HAPPEN LAST TIME.
INCENTIVIZING MORE FOREIGN
NATIONALS TO FLOOD INTO THE
COUNTRY AND THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF WHY OBAMA DID THIS A
DECADE AGO SO WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO THE ECONOMY WHICH IS ON THE
VERGE OF A DOWNTURN AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THE AVERAGE DREAMER IS 28 YEARS
OLD.
THE AVERAGE INCOME IS $26,000
FOR THE AVERAGE DREAMER.
SO THAT IS NOT ATTACKING
ANYBODY.
IT IS ONLY A SIMPLE OBSERVATION
IF THE COUNTRY IS GETTING MORE
POOR, YOU PROBABLY DON'T WANT A
LOT MORE POVERTY IMPORTANT.
AND WHY IS THAT UNTRUE, NO ONE
HAS THE ABILITY TO SAY THAT IT'S
REAL, BUT DREAMERS, OR OTHER
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE COUNTRY,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN WORKING TO HIDE THOSE
NUMBERS FOR TWO YEARS NOW FROM
THE PUBLIC.
SO MUCH FOR DEMOCRACY AND ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> AFTER THE SHORT BUS RIDE FROM
THE SHELTER ACROSS FROM MEXICO
TO CALIFORNIA, THE IMMIGRATIONS
WILL HAND THEM OVER TO THEIR
AMERICAN COUNTERPARTS AND AN
OFFICIAL PORT OF ENTRY WITH
TEMPORARY LEGAL STATUS PAPERS IN
THEIR FOLDERS.
ONCE THE CDP PROCESSES THEM IN,
THEY ARE PERMANENT LIVES WORKING
IN AMERICAN CITIES OF THEIR
CHOICE.
THESE ONES AND THOUSANDS MORE
ENTERING THE SAME WAY ALL ALONG
THE U.S. AND MEXICAN BORDER WILL
NOT HAVE THE SET OF ISSUES THAT
THE OTHERS HAVE BEING SMUGGLED
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT INCLUDES OTHER CROSSING
STATISTICS.
INSTEAD THE DHS OF JOE BIDEN
LEGALIZES THE PEOPLE BEFORE THEY
CAN COMMIT ILLEGAL ACTS THAT
THEY INTENDED WHEN THEY LEFT
HOME.
THE U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION PREAPPROVED ALL OF
THEM AS THEY WERE STILL IN
MEXICO.
>> Tucker: THAT WOULD BE
IMMIGRATION FRAUD BEING
COMMITTED BY THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, HIDING THE
NUMBERS, SO YOU DON'T REALIZE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO
YOUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
YOU HAVE NO ROLE IN THIS
WHATSOEVER, SO KEEP THAT IN MIND
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
LAME-DUCK BILL WITH MILLIONS AND
BORDER SECURITY AND IT IS
BILLIONS MORE THAN DONALD TRUMP
ASKED FOR TO BUILD A BORDER
WALL.
AND OKAY.
BUT NOW THE SAME GROUP IS GOOD
WITH THIS FOR BORDER SECURITY?
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IT IS
FAKE.
THAT YOU CAN BUILD ANY STRUCTURE
THAT YOU WANT, BUT IF THE
OFFICIALS MANNING THE GATES LIKE
JANUARY 6, OPENING THE DOORS,
THEY THINK IT'S MEANINGLESS AND
OF COURSE THOM TILLIS KNOWS THAT
TO HIS ETERNAL SHAME.
WELL, WATCH THAT HE CLEARLY HAS
NO GROUNDING IN THE PHYSICALITY
OF AMERICA.
>> WE JUST NEED TO FIND MORE
COMPUTER SCIENTISTS, DATA
ANALYSTS FROM THE U.S.
POPULATION THAT THEY NEED TO
WAKE UP AND RECOGNIZE IF WE WANT
OUR ECONOMY TO CONTINUE TO GROW
AND BUILD UPON THIS ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A WORD
PHRASE SALAD THAT THOM TILLIS
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND.
IT'S PARTLY DUE TO WHAT THOM
TILLIS ENACTED UNDER THE
CONDITIONS, BUT RATHER THAN THAT
LEGALIZE THAT, IF YOU REALLY
WANT A LOT OF THEM AROUND THE
WORLD YOU WOULD MAKE AN ACTIVE
ATTEMPT AND THEN YOU CAN TELL US
WHY.
BUT THOSE WITH HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATIONS BY THE MILLIONS NOW
YOU ARE JUST LYING TO US AND
THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN TO THE
BORDER RECENTLY, CATCHING AUTO
VIDEO, HERE ARE SOME FOOTAGE TO
TELL YOU WHO IS COMING OVER.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE?
>> I THINK LAST YEAR OVER
2 MILLION IN THE YEAR BEFORE
THAT JUST UNDER 2 MILLION.
WE HAVE SOME WITH VISAS AS WELL,
SOME THAT HAVE OVERSTAYED, THE
NUMBER IS JUST A FANTASY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> NEW YORK SAYS A THOUSAND A
MONTH AND WE HAVE ABOUT 2000 PER
DAY.
>> YES, ABOUT 2000, 2500.
>> Tucker: NOT EVERYBODY HAS
AN IDEA OF THE SCALE OF THIS AND
IS HE UPSET ABOUT THIS?
WELL, COMPUTER PROGRAMMERS FROM
1996 TALK ABOUT SOME THINGS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY HAPPENING THERE AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CROSSING ARE
NICE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO WORK
AND EVERYONE SUPPORTS THAT, BUT
THIS ALL BEING ORCHESTRATED BY
CARTELS AND SOME OF THEM WIND UP
KILLING AMERICANS.
2 IS A VERY POOR SAMPLE, BECAUSE
I'VE HAD MANY COME THROUGH HERE,
SO FIVE OVER A HUNDRED IS ONLY
5%.
SO ON THOSE CAMERAS BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND OCTOBER, 2500 THAT
INCLUDES AN INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
WITH THE BORDER PATROL.
>> AT LEAST 20% ARE CARRYING
DRUGS.
>> WE THINK THAT THERE ARE 35
YEARS NOW AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE TICKED OFF THAT ALL
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING
HERE TO POISON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
2 SO THE CLOSER THAT YOU GET TO
THE BORDER AND THIS IS TRUE OF
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS MANY
ARE HORRIFIED BY WHAT IS GOING
ON.
SO THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN SUPPORT
THIS IS BY INTENTIONALLY
IGNORING WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
JOE BIDEN AND THE REST, TODAY
THEY SAID ARE YOU GOING TO GO TO
THE BORDER WHILE YOU'RE DOWN
THERE, WATCH THIS.
2 THERE ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS GOING ON.
>> THEY ARE HAVING MORE
IMPORTANT THINGS GOING ON.
WHICH ACTUALLY HAPPENED THAT
THEY ENDED THE POLICY SO IT
WOULD HAVE STOPPED THIS AT THE
BORDER AND NOW THEY WANT TO MAKE
THE PROBLEMS WORSE AND THEY ARE
TELLING YOU WHAT THE REASON IS
AND IT DOESN'T MAKE IT ANY LES